[Music]
hey man where are they just sock to him
guess what they're not coming what
yeah right now they're in the car
driving to Vermont to start a new life
together they're gonna open up some kind
of gluten-free cupcake place called
cupcakes genius name I know what are we
gonna do with over five women can
channel the Gaylord source
[Applause]
something different
Oh see brick aboard over my own stall ah
how do we do pretty good total ticket
sales 285 bucks okay um but let me
calculate something else we spent 50
bucks on glitter okay 150 for chairs and
then like the stage stuff that sucks
and then this is the killer $300 on the
Boas because they just had to be real
ostrich feathers Ram what a diva um so
all that together we are in the hole for
a little bit of money that's terrible
are you ready
[Applause]
you